Korona virus continues to spread across
the nation as the media decide Trump is
to blame
Trump's niece provides comfort food for
the Trump haters and classical music is
apparently racist i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let others track what you do stop
at keep yourself safe at express it VPN
comm slash Ben well before we begin
let's just talk a little bit about
investing strategy you've heard all the
stories about people who got in sort of
on the ground floor of some big new
company and then they just made a
fortune and other people who are sort of
left out in the cold well there is a
group of people they're called our crowd
and they believe every accredited
investor should have access to those
early sort of chances so our crowd has
brought their pre-vetted portfolio to
you and they're giving you the
opportunity to invest early and be on
the ground floor of some of the most
promising companies in the world each
year our crowd reviews the most
promising pre-ipo companies and selects
just a few dozen to invest in and then
our crowd gives you an opportunity to
join with their same early-stage
pre-negotiated terms our crowd has
helped thousands of investors invest in
almost 200 companies to date some of
which by P ode like beyond meat orbán
bought out by companies like Nike or
Microsoft Oracle uber or Comcast Intel
and snap today one of the many
opportunities in the our crab portfolio
is an innovative dairy-free ripple foods
consumer demand for non dairy
alternatives has been growing and ripple
found a way to ensure the same high
amounts of protein as Dairy Milk with
lot less sugar and a great taste which
is why customers are already buying
ripple products over 15,000 stores now
maybe that's a great investment maybe
it's not but you actually have the
opportunity to check it out and lots of
companies like you can check them out
and maybe just maybe get in on the
ground floor of the next big thing get
in early on ripple and other unique
opportunities at our crowd comm slash
Shapiro the our crowd account is free
just go to our crowd comm slash Shapiro
that is our crowd comm slash Shapiro oh
you are CRO WD comm slash Shapiro okay
so big news continues to be the spread
of coronavirus across the nation on a
day to day level the the deaths seem to
be somewhat stable we've seen around a
thousand deaths for the last three days
as well as a lot of last week we have
seen hospitalizations starting to
slightly decline in some places like
Texas and Arizona so it's possible that
we've art we've already hit peaked there
in Florida doesn't look like they've hit
peak yet hospital capacity is not being
threatened so far as I can tell from the
statistics in places like Florida or to
or Arizona which means that the curve
was indeed flattened nor are we seeing
the sorts of death rates that we saw in
New York in New York we're seeing 600
700 deaths every single day in New York
City alone in Arizona in Florida and
Texas in California you're seeing on the
upper end about 150 deaths a day which
obviously is tragic and horrifying and
that number if it were to last the
entire year would be absolutely stunning
right then you would see 35,000 deaths
in a lot of these places but we have not
reached New York epidemic levels as of
yet so the media continue to focus in on
the fact that this thing is spreading
uncontrolled across the country and that
is true I mean the fact is the number of
positive cases continues to increase
yesterday the u.s. shattered its single
day record for new cases with more than
75 thousand 600 cases according to the
New York Times this was the 11th time in
the past month that the record has been
broken the number has more than doubled
since June 24th when the county when the
country registered 37,000 14 cases after
a lull in the outbreak had kept the
previous record 36,000 738 standing for
2 months now in reality is it possible
we saw many many more infections like
this in the early stages absolutely but
testing was not ramped up to nearly the
extent that it is now so it's quite
possible that for example the death
rates were exactly the same today as
they were back during the New York days
it's just that the testing capacity was
not nearly what it was so the
denominator in the deaths over
infections rate was just not correct as
possible the denominator was way larger
than it was originally purported to be
in the previous single day record 68,000
241 cases was announced last Friday
Thursday's record included more than
5,000 cases in Bexar County Texas which
contains San Antonio there was a backlog
in test report and one of the weird
things about the stats here is there are
these backlogs that sometimes get
reported late so you'll see occasionally
a very odd day where a huge number of
deaths are tallied and you're like whoa
dude just a bunch of people by that days
you know that's a backlog and that's
being reported now you're seeing this
with some of the cases that are being
reported you're also seeing cases where
possible kovat is being reported as
probable or real covett you've seen
cases in in Florida where hospitals are
reporting only positive results which
takes up the the % positive rate now
does any of this change the underlying
narrative that kovat is actually quite
prevalent across the country and is
apparently rising in terms of case
number no of course that's true the
question at this point is number one
does it overwhelm the healthcare system
and number two are we actually seeing a
decline
rate of death now again a declining rate
of death with heavy levels of infection
is still very dangerous it let's say
that this thing were it had a point to
death right about twice as deadly as the
flu wait say that that was the actual
death rate on this thing and let's say
that it's three times as infectious as
the flu well then you're talking about
something that will end up with you know
six times as many deaths it's three
times as infectious it's twice as deadly
as the flu and so you end up with you
know 250,000 deaths
that's a horrifying horrifying thing but
the bottom line to all of this is that
nobody knows anything and one of the
narratives the media seems to be driving
is that we know the answer to this we
know the answer to this and when
everyone else points to the fact that
nobody really knows the answer to this
that we've seen the same policies
adopted by Democrats and Republicans in
different states to different to
different outcomes that Georgia opened
the exact same time is Colorado Colorado
who's seen a 40 percent decline in cases
while Georgia has seen a 200% increase
in cases and they pursued the exact same
policy at the exact same time well says
we don't understand the virus very much
we don't know the dynamics to the virus
the virus very much when when people in
the media point to lockdowns work and
then you say well hold up California
never really wet out a lockdown in
California is one of the one of the
states that is spiking right now the
there seems to be no counter to that the
media because they are seeking epistemic
closure here because they are looking
for a a scientific model where they can
say follow the science and if you
disagree with us you're not following
the science because the media are doing
this they're neglecting the fact that
there are no great answers here there
just aren't okay they keep pointing at
New York look at New York New York's
doing great 34 thousand people died in
New York it is possible that there are
antibodies in like 50 to 60 percent of
certain populations in New York because
the thing ran roughshod through the
population so comparing New York where
they had a massive wave where everybody
got infected with texas or Florida where
there was no massive first wave and
they're now experiencing a first wave of
cases is utterly foolhardy the same
thing is true when it comes to a wide
variety of issues for example let's talk
about masking for a second so I have
said many many times and out of an
abundance of caution I'm in favor of
masking that if you're in a crowded
place it seems to me that the least you
can do is put on a mask when you go into
the Walmart I think it's a good idea I
think it's a smart idea and if it's not
100% foolproof but it's better than
nothing and if a lot of people do it
then you are reducing risk
through a herd adoption of the measure
that that lowers risk by a certain
percentage that we don't actually know
right but let's be real about this the
evidence on masks is fairly divisive hey
up until the last five minutes the w-h-o
suggested it if you were asymptomatic
you should not be wearing a mask in fact
I believe the whu-oh still holds to that
standard and in fact there are many
countries that have done just fine with
this thing that have not really done the
masking thing in fact for example there
is a there's a chart showing whether
Europeans are wearing masks okay this is
done just a couple of weeks ago you got
asked European citizens if they would
wear a mask in public places and what
you can see in the chart is that under
10% of people from Denmark Finland
Norway and Sweden say they would wear a
mask in public places
that's not your sweet and right I mean
that's Denmark and Finland and Norway as
well meanwhile you got 85% of the
population in places like Italy saying
they would wear I'm asking Italy just
got creamed
you've got other countries like Spain
that have an uptick in the number of
people who say that they would wear eye
masks and you've got the UK where a huge
number of people say they would wear a
mask those place have been really really
hard hit so if it's just about the mask
wearing then why is it that some
countries that have been really hard hit
didn't do the masking in some countries
that did do the mask wearing have been
really hard hit like what exactly is
happening here and the answer is nobody
really knows anything we're now four
months into lockdown and and revised
lockdown in the United States and people
still don't know anything Jim Garrity at
national view points this out he points
out that the most common strain of kovat
19 in the u.s. right now is extremely
contagious and will prove difficult to
contain even with wider and more
consistent adoption of best practices
I'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that as
you do your business this year you
cannot afford an extra cost
you know it's an extra cost paying the
lawyers lawyers are really expensive
they'll charge you on an hourly basis
they create this magnificent transaction
cost that is difficult to get rid of or
theoretically you could go check out
LegalZoom right now don't let legal
questions hold your business back
legalism has been dedicated to helping
you with the right solutions for more
than 19 years if you're looking to
protect your family with a will or a
living trust or if you're thinking about
the right way to start a business with
the DBA LLC nonprofit or more LegalZoom
has you covered
it's easy to get started online if you
need guidance there
network of attorneys can provide advice
to ensure you make the right choices and
since Legal Zoom is not a law firm
you're not gonna have to leave your home
and you won't get charged by the our
visit legalzoom.com today take care of
some of the important things you need to
get done for your business and for
yourself new wills and living trusts and
all that and you can do your business
documents as well that's legalzoom.com
LegalZoom where life meets legal go
check them out right now Legal Zoom
doing great work i-i've been using Legal
Zoom I'm a lawyer I'm using Legal Zoom
for many many years long before they
were an advertiser on the program
they've saved me time they've saved me
money and they make it really easy for
you right now check them out at
legalzoom.com check them out right now
instead of paying a lawyer a fortune
legalzoom.com okay so as Jim Garrity
points out a study released last month
by the Scripps Research Institute
concluded that the strains of the virus
spreading so quickly in Europe in the US
have a mutated s spike protein that
makes them about ten times as infectious
as the strain initially identified in
Asia so now you're comparing apples to
oranges when you say why isn't this
thing spreading in Hong Kong or Taiwan
the same way that it spread in the
United States or Europe that ain't
exactly the same virus as it turns out
if it seems like the u.s. is having a
tougher time controlling the spread of
coronavirus than asian countries didn't
winter and early spring that's partially
because this version of the virus is
tougher to stop from spreading more and
more researchers such as Jim Garrity are
contending that SARS cover to cover 19
is airborne meaning it is not merely
being dispersed by the bodily fluids of
those who have it but also floating
about in aerosolized form it's also
possible the virus is not truly
aerosolized but it's floating in tiny
droplets so light and small they can
easily be carried long distances by air
currents the European Center for Disease
prevention and the World Health
Organization are now taking the
aerosolized possibility seriously and
with good reason an aerosolized virus
would mean most of our current pandemic
control policies like remaining six feet
apart are not enough by themselves to
prevent contraction of the virus as Jim
Garrity says the scale and complexity of
the problem should not be understated
the country enacted unprecedented
sweeping lock downs that kept most
Americans at home at great cost of the
economy the lockdown slowed the spread
they didn't stop it preventing more
infections is not just a matter of
convincing the President to wear a mask
consistently or shutting down beaches or
subways or requiring quarantines for
those who travel between states at every
level of government the response to the
virus has met with mixed success but
it's important to recognize no one is
ignoring any simple or easy solutions
because the solutions do not exist now
one thing that is true is that the death
rate has been dropping fairly
dramatically the CDC
he estimates the death rate at between
point six and point seven percent about
seven times as deadly as the flu
a new study puts it between 0.5 and
points 8 if there are a lot of
asymptomatic or unconfirmed cases that
means it could be point 2 but as I say
even a point 2 fatality rate with half
of the American population adopting the
virus would mean a lot of dead people so
we will see whether there is a big spike
here maybe not but the bottom line is
that everybody who's sort of counting on
a vaccine to save us that is not a
strategy either the fact is that if we
rush out of vaccine and it's no good
then it's no good it's also possible
that vaccine that is truly effective and
and mass-produced and mass adopted won't
happen until mid time next year even in
the most optimistic scenarios so the
notion that you're just gonna be able to
sort of sit around and wait for good
things to happen just stay at home and
wait for good things to happen that's
not true either
the reason I'm pointing all of this out
is because this is all hard stuff this
is all hard stuff I'm looking right now
at a list from world ometer which
compiles data from Johns Hopkins
University about kovat 19 deaths and I'm
gonna give you the states that have the
highest rate of deaths for 1 million
population right now okay this is the
list New Jersey New York Connecticut
Massachusetts Rhode Island District of
Columbia Louisiana Michigan Illinois
then Maryland Pennsylvania Delaware
Mississippi Indiana Arizona Colorado
Georgia New Hampshire Minnesota New
Mexico Ohio Alabama Iowa Virginia
Florida right Florida is all the way
down there
California is next on the list by the
way Florida South Carolina Nevada
California what one thing that you will
notice is if you're gonna talk about
strategies that worked one two three
four five six seven eight nine the top
nine states in terms of death per
million population are all democratic
governed and nearly all of them were pro
lockdown right New Jersey New York
Connecticut Massachusetts Rhode Island
DC Louisiana Michigan these were all
very Pro lockdown states Maryland is a
Republican governed state Larry Hogan is
the governor over there and he's been
widely praised for his response to the
virus we've had him on the radio show he
was Pro lockdown his state ranks about
10 to 15 slots above Florida in terms of
the number of deaths per million Ohio
has a higher deaths per million stat in
Florida now it may not stay that way but
the notion that anyone has figured out
how to solve this thing is just
bleep loony like there is no evidence
that anyone has come up with the Silver
Bullet on how to deal with Cove in
nineteen so when you hear people
screaming to the sky Ron de santis Greg
Abbott
lockdowns no lock down sirens understand
nobody knows anything here's the thing
there are no experts on an unprecedented
disease there are experts on disease
generally but they are not experts on
this disease which means that there's
gonna be a lot of conflicting evidence
from experts and get Scott Atlas on the
one hand saying I'm not sure that masks
are supremely useful and get dr. Fauci
saying masks aren't useful and in masks
are useful you can get pouchy saying at
one point I'm not sure we can go back
into full-scale lockdown and then you
can have foutch e saying well we never
should have let out a lockdown and the
first listing if you just look at the
statements of Falchi who by the way I
think he's doing his best just like
everybody else in this situation factory
statements contradict each other fairly
regularly because again no one knows
anything so when you see the media
trotting out this level of epistemic
certainty we know how to stop no you
don't know how to solve this you don't
know this is true i masks it is for on
social distancing in destroying whether
this is aerosolized it is true on
whether kids should be in schools right
on the one hand you've got a fair bit of
evidence that kids are not infecting
their parents there's good evidence from
Iceland that this is the case there's
good evidence from China this is the
case on the other hand you saw a vast
outbreak in Israel when they reopened
the schools now it turns out when they
reopen the schools it's quite possible
one of the things that happen is that
the adults actually infected the other
adults right kids are getting the
infection they're not dying from the
infection a lot of kids can get it if
they don't die from it you know
that's not that bad the problem is if
they pass it on to their parents that's
what happened in Israel kids gave it to
each other and then like a couple of
people got it some of the adults and the
adults started spreading it amongst
themselves particularly in religious
communities is that a reason to keep
schools closed
probably not but the notion that there
are any like easy hard and fast answers
here is just very silly now I know some
wrong answers here yeah I know for
example that it is a stupid answer for
the New York City mayor's who suggest
that we were gonna have mass paid at
child care but not schools like that
makes no sense at all like just on a
common sensical level that's idiotic
New York Mayor Bill de Blasio announced
Thursday the city will provide free
childcare it's 100,000 students when
schools reopen in September last week
the city released its plan for
children's return to public school
classrooms 1 to 3 days a week depending
on each school's capacity for social
distancing I'm
the corona virus pandemic students will
take classes remotely on the other days
the city aims to provide relief for
working parents who either can't afford
to stay home or can't find childcare for
the days students aren't in school for
in-person learning the program will
serve students from age three through
eighth grade there will be 50,000
available seats each day but the idea
that these seats will serve a hundred
thousand students because of alternating
in-person days at school the city says
it's trying to identify space in schools
community centers libraries and
elsewhere so basically are gonna have
school except the teachers don't have to
show up and teach it's just a stop to
the teachers union by saying okay so we
will keep your kid locked up in the
state care facility but the teachers
won't have to show up so this is stupid
because it's just as stupid as the anti
lockdown protest will spread covered but
pro George Floyd protests will not
spread covin and saying that child care
is not going to spread kovat but schools
are gonna like what the teaching spreads
the Kovan this of course is very similar
there are certain things that you can
see done in policy that are done right
leaving the nursing homes open to Colvin
stupid opening child care but not school
stupid makes no sense and by the way has
some pretty dire secondary effect I'm
amused that the New York Times the same
New York Times the same we need to keep
the schools closed for the sake of the
teachers is also observing that by the
way a lot of private schools are coming
back and rich parents can deal with kids
being home and they can homeschool them
it's creating an actual more serious gap
in education between poor and rich my
kids have done fairly okay in terms of
education being home during the Sun my
six-year-old started off be pandemic
reading it probably first grade level
when she was in kindergarten and now
before she enters first grade she's
reading a third grade level right she's
got me at home she's got her mom at home
she's got her grandparents there so
she's been doing just great but what
about kids who don't have that sort of
support structure at home and aren't
doing the Xoom classes what do they do
the New York Times is recognizing this
is exacerbating inequality at the same
time they are cheering on the closing of
the schools and shouting a president
Trump for saying the school should open
so get some more of this in a second
because if you believe that the media
are objective and then you see the way
that they weaponize uncertainty against
Trump it's pretty it's pretty
astonishing we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact you need your sleep I know I need
my sleep let me tell you about my night
last night okay so I go to bed at 10:00
and I fall asleep on my magnificent
helix sleep mattress and then my baby
wakes me up at 11:00 and then my baby
looks me up at 1:30 and then my baby
wakes me up at 4:30
and then my son wakes me up at 5:45 what
does this mean it means that those spare
moments when I actually get to sleep I
need to be on a comfortable mattress
made just for me and this is where helix
sleep comes in helix sleep has a quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you whether you're a side sleeper or a
hot sleeper whether you like a plush or
from bed with helix there's no more
confusion and no more compromising helix
sleep is rated the number one mattress
by GQ and Wired magazine CNN has called
it the most comfortable mattress they've
ever slept on just go to helix sleep
comm slash men take their two-minute
sleep quiz they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk-free and we even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but indeed you will helix is offering up
to 200 bucks off all mattress orders
just for our listeners a up to 200 bucks
off at helix sleep comm slash patent
that is helix sleep comm slash Ben it's
a mattress made just for you and it is
indeed spectacular helix offering 200
saw fall mattress orders it is risk free
checking out at helix sleep comm slash
bed okay so the media have their
narrative the media's narratives that
Trump is ignoring at the science now
there's only one problem with this which
is the Trump isn't actually ignoring the
science hit run provided the ventilators
there's good science to suggest that
people need to go back to schools I know
of private schools and some public
schools that are looking at reopening
and they're doing their best I mean it's
a rough situation we're talking about my
kids prospective school and they're
gonna have the kids check in or do me
temperature checks at the front door
they're gonna be trying to socially
distance the kids there have the kids
stay in the room and the teachers move
from room to room as opposed to having
the kids move around in in the hallways
he's gonna be rough it's gonna be rough
but the idea that the schools can remain
indefinitely closed or they can close
down all of American society forever
that's just not a realistic scenario and
everybody knows it everybody understands
this except the media which says that
anything Trump says is bad so a perfect
example of media bias yesterday so then
here's the New York Times headline okay
the White House press secretary says
science should not stand in the way of
reopening schools okay so that is their
actual headline that the science should
not stand in the way so that makes it
sound like Caylee mcenany who actually
is quite good at her job that Caylee
mcenany was saying that we should ignore
the science and send kid back to school
and this leads Rob Reiner the the
director to tweet out Donald Trump wants
to murder your children it's like no
your that's that's the demagogue on from
stranger things Rob no Trump does not
wanna murder children and that's also
not what Kaylie mcenany said here's the
actual clip of Kaylie mcenany she never
says at any point that we should ignore
the science in fact she's saying
precisely the opposite she's saying
there's plenty of science to back the
idea we should open the schools the
president has said unmistakeably that he
wants schools to open and I was just in
the Oval talking him about that and when
he says open he means open and full kids
being able to attend each and every day
at their school the science should not
stand in the way of this and as dr.
Scott Atlas said I thought this was a
good quote of course we can do it
everyone else in the Western world our
peer nations are doing it we are the
outlier here the science is very clear
on this that you know for instance you
look at the JAMA pediatric study of 46
pediatric hospitals in North America
that said the risk of critical illness
from kovat is far less for children than
that of seasonal flu the science is on
our side here okay so the science is on
our side here is not the same thing as
ignore the science and reopen the
schools the media run with the actual
lie they don't bother with the actual
truth which is that she's making a
scientific case for reopening schools
and the scientific case by the way is
fairly strong the media are touting an
article today by Maryland governor Larry
Hogan who I think you know he's done his
best during this pandemic right that the
fact again is that MIT is that the rate
of death per million population in
Maryland is 556 per million population
the rate of death in Florida right now
the foot the much-maligned Florida is
218 right less than half less than half
of the death per million rate of
Maryland
hey the rate in a lot of Republican
states as it turns out is really really
tech psious right which a much-maligned
texas 130 per million a lot lot lower
like four times lower then Larry Hogan's
Maryland but according to Larry Hogan
it's all about Trump right he has a
piece in The Washington Post and this is
the nice thing about having an unpopular
president you can always blame
everything on the unpopular president he
says I'd watched as the president
downplayed the outbreak severity and as
the White House failed to issue public
warnings draw up a 50-state strategy or
dispatch medical gear or life-saving
ventilators from the national stockpile
to American hospitals by the way there
was no shortage of ventilators he no one
died from want some events later in the
United States it did not happen
he says eventually it was clear that
waiting around for
president to run the nation's response
was hopeless if we delayed any longer
we'd be condemning more of our citizens
to suffering and death so every governor
went their own way which is how the
United States ended up with such a
patchwork response I did the best I
could from aerelon okay now that's also
called federalism and the idea that
states get to respond to things like
pandemics with the best they can do
that's our system the idea the president
has a solution to this you can't just
cram down everything whatsit let's
assume that Trump had said you know what
national masks mandate which is
unconstitutional they can't do that on
national level you don't have the public
health power really but let's say the
Trump did it they would claim you as a
fascist let's say he said we're going to
lock everybody in their homes for the
next three months until no one has a
case of this do you think people would
have stood for that do you think
Democrats would have stood for that
especially when Democrats were claiming
that you could not get co19 if you
protested for George Floyd and shouted
at the cops how do you think that
would've gone so no matter what Trump
did here he was doomed late Trump is
overtly not fascist he says I'm not
going to nationalize our systems I'm not
gonna take everything over and then they
say well you know you abdicated duty and
if he had done it then he'd be a fascist
that's the way this works I don't have a
lot of sympathy for the for the idea
that Trump's to blame for all of this
you see this again from from Chris Hayes
but Chris Hayes on MSNBC he says it's
Republicans fault because they are not
pushing mask mandates here he was Chris
Hayes on MSNBC they want the last few
months to not have happened to be wiped
from everyone's memories to be some some
fluke an alternate dimension that we
have accidentally warped into and now
we're just gonna work back out into
normalcy and they govern that way - by
and large and it hasn't worked that's
why we're in the hell we are and that is
exactly what the fight about mass is
about I think masks are a visual
reminder that everything isn't normal
that we are in the midst of a
once-in-a-century pandemic and on the
whole the Republican Party would very
much like you to forget that okay that
hold up a second just hold up a second
hey the idea that masks mandates are the
real problem here again I'm gonna give
you the case numbers the rising case
numbers okay so Florida is number one in
terms of rising case numbers they're
also doing the most tests it goes
Florida Texas California which is a
democratic state Georgia
Arizona Tennessee Louisiana Louisiana's
a democratic state
okay this
that were most hard-hit at the beginning
of course we're all of the Democratic
states this idea that the mask mandate
was the real key here so then were white
all that I'm at states get get hit and
why is it again that does Trump have the
power to mandate the Denmark and Norway
and Sweden and Finland don't wear masks
you know again the idea that they have
like the clear answer to all of this is
really just cover for we don't like
Trump and that's what you see from
Andrew Cuomo who's been the worst
governor throughout all of this awful in
every respect and then makes posters to
himself about how wonderful he is here
was Andrew Cuomo basically saying that
Trump is to blame for everything
including the fact that I'm garbage at
my job a per should say that Trump is to
blame for the virus coming to New York
because that's the fact that's what the
CDC just said if Trump's government had
done its job the virus wouldn't come
here
we don't do governors don't do global
pandemics I was trying to explain that
to mr. Tapper state governments don't do
global public health that's not in the
state charter the federal government
does that the virus didn't come here
because of anything New Yorkers did the
virus came here because the federal
government missed it oh the virus came
here to the federal government missed it
III see it didn't come to New York
because you guys were busy talking about
how everybody should go down to
Chinatown for Chinese New Year and it
didn't come to New York because you had
shipped all the old people with Kovac
back into the nursing homes and Trump is
just such a convenient whipping host for
the Democrats that it doesn't matter
that they don't have a solution for this
either because no one has a solution how
about this how about we just recognize
there are no good answers here okay
coming up we're going to get into
another aspect of the the anti Trump
campaign which is when he doesn't do it
when he when he's not a fascist it's
because he's incompetent and when he and
when he does something strong then he's
a fascist right this is the catch-22 for
Trump will get to that in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that maybe your sleep quality is often
maybe one of the reasons your sleep
quality is off is because you have been
staring at blue light right before bed
maybe that's also why I get in the
headaches and the eye strain well this
is why you require Felix gray glasses
Felix gray they filter out 90% of blue
light in the most damaging range they
eliminate 99% of glare through a
proprietary industry-leading lens
technology only available if Felix grey
9 and 10 Felix Craig customers report a
significant symptom relief
Felix gray frames their hand-finished
durable super lightweight Italian
acetate number 200,000 happy customers
Felix gray isn't just the right choice
it's the only choice I spend an enormous
amount time every day in front of
screens it's why I really need my Felix
gray glasses exposure to blue light can
really mess you up this is why you need
Felix Gray's go to Felix great glasses
calm /ban for the absolute best quality
blue light filtering glasses on the
market they're durable and they are
great and they last basically forever
that's Felix great glasses calm slash
bands what I did start taking care of
your eyes feel better work smarter and
look good doing it shipping and returns
totally free at Felix gray Felix great
glasses calm and /ban again that's Felix
gray glasses dot-com slash Ben go check
them out right now I promise you will
enjoy these glasses to looks great
glasses calm slash Ben okay meanwhile as
I say the idea is that Trump was not a
fascist on cope at nineteen and
therefore he abdicated his duty and then
when Trump steps in to protect the
rights of citizens that are not being
protected by their own mayor's then he's
a fascist so case in point today there
are these reports happening from
Portland where apparently federal forces
under the DHS are going around Portland
they are labeled police right there
wearing full-on military regalia with
police on their military regalia and
they're getting out of unmarked vehicles
and they're arresting looters and
rioters and people who are disobeying
curfew laws in all of this and they're
not just quote unquote peaceful
protesters and walking around at 2:00
a.m. smashing things that's what's been
happening in Portland for well over a
month
Ted wheeler who is the the idiot mayor
of Portland has allowed this to go on
for really years he's allowed and Tifa
to stop people in the middle of the
street he's allowed Portland to become
the repository of sort of antifa centers
so they're videos that are emerging of
federal forces and members of DHS or
walking up on guys who are who are
dressed in these kind of cosplay an tyfa
military stuff and arresting people and
so there are all these reports emerging
look at the feds this is fascism
fascism because they're coming and
arresting people what's it all about
well DHS basically announced what it was
all about before let me read you how the
media are covering this and then well
guess what's actually happening here
because according to the media this is
basically Trump has authorized the
jackboots to come in at night and just
pick up peaceful protesters standing
against racism that is not what is
happening here there's not a lot of
evidence that the federal forces are
just arriving to lock up the protesters
that's that's not okay so here is the
report
they got all of this started it's from
the Oregon I guess it's Oregon Public
Broadcasting is the the source of this
report in the early hours of July 15th
after a night spent protesting at the
moment County Justice Center protesting
will see by protesting they mean like
firing bangs breaking windows and
attempting to destroy and the mark
Hatfield federal courthouse mark
Pettibone and his friend Connor Roche
decided to head home it had been a calm
night compared to most protesting
downtown by 2:00 a.m. law enforcement
hadn't used any tear gas and with only a
few exceptions both the Portland Police
Bureau and federal law enforcement
officers had stayed out of sight a block
west of Chapman Square Pettibone and
O'Shea bumped into a group of people who
warned them that people in camouflage
were driving around the area in unmarked
minivans grabbing people off the street
so first of all let's just be clear
about this police routinely use unmarked
vehicles hey because if you're in a
marked vehicle people run if you want to
arrest somebody very often you use an
unmarked vehicle LAPD is not only use
marked vehicles in my city federal
forces are not required to only use
marked vehicles that was terrifying to
hear Pettibone said they'd barely made
it half a block when an unmarked minivan
pulled up in front of them I see guys in
camo Shaye said four or five of them pop
out open the door was just like Oh bleep
I don't know who you are or what you
want with us federal law enforcement
officers have been using unmarked
vehicles to drive around downtown
Portland and detain protesters since at
least July 14 now you need probable
cause to to arrest somebody it's not
clear whether these arrests are arrests
or detentions people have been released
it's not like they're locking them up in
Guantanamo Bay and leaving them there
there's probably if I had to suggest a
theory here is my theory that the feds
had been monitoring a group of Antipa
protesters for a long time a tape of
them and then they're going out and
resting them when they're violating
curfew at night personal accounts and
multiple videos posted online show the
officers driving up to people detaining
individuals with no explanation of why
they are being arrested and driving off
the tactic appears to be another
escalation in federal force deployed on
Portland city streets as federal
officers and President Donald Trump have
said they plan to quell nightly protests
outside the federal courthouse and moma
County Justice Center that have lasted
for more than six weeks
federal officers have charged at least
13 people with crimes related to the
protest so far they're not crimes
related to the protests they are crimes
of looting and rioting and violating the
law others have been arrested and
released including Pettibone they also
left one demonstrator hospitalized with
skull fractures after shooting him in
the face with so called less lethal
munitions
on July 11th officers from the US
Marshal Special Ops group and Customs
and Border Protection have been sent to
Portland to protect federal property but
interviews conducted by OBP show
officers are also detaining people in
Portland streets who aren't near federal
property nor is it clear that all the
people being arrested have engaged in
criminal activity well if they are
detained and then they're released that
does happen from time to time and when
the police detain you and then they
release you that is not technically an
arrest by Supreme Court jurisprudence
you know what is it what exactly why is
all this happening if you just read that
piece you think oh well these are
peaceful protesters right I mean that's
all that's happening it's just peaceful
peaceful protesting
yeah that's not exactly what has been
happening you have terrorists who are
attempting to tear now I mean look at
these tapes and look at Luke the
defacement of public property you can
see what's happening here okay they're
having to use tear gas on proton
quote-unquote protesters and looters who
are flinging objects at the cops they're
firing fireworks literally firing
fireworks at federal buildings the this
is this is not peaceful protesting
acting ths secretary Chad Wolfe said in
a statement earlier this week
the city of Portland has been under
siege for 47 straight days by a violent
mob while local political leaders refuse
to restore order to protect their city
each night Wallace anarchists destroy
and desecrate property including the
federal courthouse and attacked the
brave law enforcement officers
protecting it he said instead of
addressing violent criminals in their
communities local and state leaders are
instead focusing on placing blame on law
enforcement and requesting fewer
officers in their community this failed
response has only embolden the violent
mob as it escalates violence day after
day the DHS then released an extensive
list of violence caused by leftist
protesters since basically the end of
May we're talking about graffiti we're
talking about assault I mean that
there's tape literally last night a van
Tifa dragging fencing over toward the
federal courthouse to try and set up
their own chopped Chas Inn in Portland
so why exactly here they are right here
they are they they face the federal
court building and now they are dragging
fencing over there to prevent the cops
from coming in that's a bunch of idiot
white kids it's a bunch of more
woke white liberals who are engaging in
this sort of activity
okay that's criminal activity and the
locals refused to do their job and
arrest the criminals and so the feds are
coming in and they're doing it which is
legal which is legal so the media's
response has been Trump's of fashion's
this is the overwhelming response
literally Trump is a fascist was
trending on Twitter today
so if Trump enforces the law he's a
fascist if from doesn't take over all
aspects of America's lockdown policies
then he is an incompetent you guys are
gonna have to pick one we're gonna have
to pick the other but again it all comes
down to the cops or the bad guys except
the cops aren't the bad guys there's one
black officer from Portland who I mean
this is pretty moving stuff talked about
the situation in Portland he said
basically I won't have conversations
with some of the people who are
protesting and these white woke
jackasses keep coming between me and the
people that I'm talking to and then
calling me racist names here is this
this black police officer from Portland
his name is Jackson I got to see folks
that really do want change like the rest
of us that have been impacted by racism
and then I got to see those people get
faded out by people that have no idea
what racism is all about a lot of times
someone of color black Hispanic Asian
come up to the fence and directly want
to talk to me hey what do you think
about George Floyd
what do you think about what happened
about this I go up to the fence so when
white comes up if the police don't talk
to him that was the most bizarre thing
because I could see it coming okay he
says in this clip also that some of
these white protesters for coming up to
him and say I've never seen a nose that
big overtly racist stuff and yet these
are the good guys according to the media
the protesters are the good guys the
cops are the bad guys and this fits into
a broader narrative that the cops are
the bad guys generally we're gonna get
to that in just one second cuz that ties
into the broader narrative that America
is racist in Trump is the is the
figurehead of all that racism he's the
prow of the racist ship we'll get to
that in just one moment first let's talk
about the fact that you probably don't
feel like going to the post office right
now like who the hell does feel like
going to the post office right now post
office is great they do a lot of great
stuff you don't want to be standing in
line a lot of people who might be
sneezing or coughing or anything like
that instead why don't just do all this
from home and save a bunch of money by
doing so with stamps calm you can print
postage on to man and skip those lines
and crowds at the post office plus you
can actually save some money with
discounts you can't even get at the post
office as if that wasn't enough stamps
calm also offers UPS services with
discounts up to 62 percent and no UPS
residential surcharges here at daily
wear we've used stamps calm
20:17 no more wasting our time
stamps.com brings all the services of
the US Postal Service directly to your
computer in the safety and comfort of
your own home office anywhere or
anywhere else you are hunkering down
right now
whether a small business sending
invoices or an online sellers shipping
out products or you're just working from
home and you need to mail stuff
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it like I said with
stamps calm yet great discounts to five
cents off every first class stamp and up
to 62 percent off shipping rates stamps
calms a no-brainer especially an out
saves you time it saves you money it
keeps you safe in these crazy times
right now my listeners get a special
offered includes a four week trial plus
free postage ands digital scale no long
term commitment just go to stamps calm
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage type in Shapiro that is
stamps calm type in Shapiro check them
out right now we use it a daily where
you should do all right we got to get
more of this in a second the assault on
the police that this is part of a
broader sort of argument the police are
evil and Trump because he's Pro police
is evil and the police and from PI
racist well guess that in a second first
is that glorious time of the week when I
give a shout out to a daily where I
remember we have reached that point
today it's Ali Burkholder on Instagram
who's keeping on top of the coveted 19 a
pandemic in the picture Ali's elite
tumbler is resting on a table next to a
well-organized set of medical testing
supplies the caption reads drinking my
morning tea out of the very greatest of
beverage vessels the leftist ears tumblr
while doing my part to study the spread
of Cova 19 weekly blood tests a nasal
swab all negative results so far
thumbs up hope it stays that way we do
too glad to hear you're healthy hope you
stay that way as well thanks for the
picture thanks for being a daily wire
member by the way my new book how to
destroy America in three easy steps it
goes on sale Tuesday July 21st
6:00 p.m. Eastern 3 p.m. Pacific will be
doing a virtual live signing event the
day of release with your purchase of a
signed copy you can write in a question
which may be read and answered as I sign
your book live on the air you can
pre-order your signed copy right in your
question at daily wear calm
/ - I've been talking about the book is
really about what is going on in the
country right now a vision of America
that says that America's history is evil
America's philosophy is evil America's
culture of Rights is evil and a
traditional vision of America that
unifies us that is the battle going on
between not even just left and right
unionist people want to hold the Union
together and disintegration us
disintegration is want to use cancel
culture and cruelty and malice and the
power of government
build a whole new world order by tearing
everything down the book is how to
destroy America in three easy steps
it is the antidote to everything that is
going on right now you should get a copy
for yourself and get a copy for a
liberal friend cuz I think it's vital
that everybody read this I don't think
you have to be a conservative to agree
with this book
check out daily wire comm slash Ben to
order your signed copy today join my
live signing on Tuesday July 21st
you are listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so the argument about the
cops in in Portland and the law
enforcement in Portland when it has just
been run by NT Pfeffer a month and a
half is it's it's really insane and
really a drive it's driven by the
broader American narrative that the
police are the bad guys and the
narrative here is based on a
extraordinary reading of history Iona
Presley was the representative from
Massachusetts she is the ringo starr of
the squad and she actually said
yesterday that our policing system
emerged from slave catching now that is
a bit of a stretch the idea that the
cops right now are trying to stop black
people from being murdered are an
extension of a system that was designed
to catch black people and bring them
back to slavery is patently crazy but
this is part of the narrative the cops
are just all of history is just one
unified blob nothing has progressed over
time and so the cops are just mere
outgrowths of that according to Jana
Presley while Juneteenth is meant to be
a day of celebration and a freedom and
emancipation again we must take stock of
this moment and be sober about the work
that lies ahead mr. krenshaw is it fair
to say that the policing system in our
nation grew out of the practice of
capturing and often murdering
individuals trying to escape from hiss
from slavery could you speak to the
distance our policing system and how you
see that influencing modern-day policing
okay
that that linkage is so crazy how do you
see it influencing modern-day policing
that in 1832 there were slave catching
bands that were going around and they
were called police and they were going
around catching slaves like come on
again this is part of the broader
narrative prokop you're racist and this
also ties into the narrative that the
way you make your city safer is Bennett
by getting rid of the cops despite all
evidence to the contrary is how you can
have more on Mayor Bill DeBlasio
literally say yesterday that for seven
years we've made the city safer except
for you know the doubling of the murder
rates in New York City over the past
month and a half
here's more on giant weirdo groundhog
murderer Bill DeBlasio for seven years
we have made this city safer and safer
by working with communities by
recognizing the leadership of community
leaders organizations clergy
officials seeing what people can do to
build peace in their own community and
building a different and better
relationship between communities and the
NYPD it's true you have made the city
safer and safer except for all the dead
people except for that you've been doing
a fantastic job there bill de blasio but
again if the narrative is the cops or
the bad guys then you can claim this is
true even when it is not true the mere
absence of cops makes everybody safer
according to people like bill de blasio
now again this ties into the broader
narrative about Trump so much of what is
going on right now is simply about Trump
about the fact that the left cannot
accept the Trump won the 2016 election
they've never been able to accept it and
so the idea must be that the people who
voted for him are not only in league
with the Russians which was the argument
for two years they are vicious racists
and you can see this in some of the
media coverage right the actual the
actual heads of the New York Times and
Medine baquette he suggested that as
soon as the Russia stuff was over before
the whole Ukrainian nonsense that he was
going to have to staff up on racial
issues I'm go back and look at it
do you maquette said that they're going
to staff up on racial issues because
that was the new narrative well why was
that the new narrative because the media
have decided to drive that narrative and
so what they're looking for right now is
to link everybody who voted with Trump
with the deplorable z-- again right
everybody who voted for Trump is indeed
a vicious brutal horrible racist and
indeed all of American society is
plagued by racism so not only is all of
American society plagued by racism but
also the top of the heap is Trump Trump
is the face of that American racism and
this is why you have this masturbatory
adulation for Mary Trump's new book so
marry Trump is Trump sneeze I literally
have no idea what she does or where she
came from or why she is relevant right I
have extended relatives they don't know
me all that well now I I don't know if
I'm running for president I would not
really trust what they had to write in a
book I do not know why if married Trump
is such a relevant figure she has only
come about in 2020 when it was time for
her to write a book nonetheless the very
first day that this book was on sale the
Mary Trump's book it sold nine hundred
and fifty thousand copies why well
because it's just it's comfort food it's
comfort food for Democrats who can't get
over the fact that Trump won and now
Mary from is is making allegations that
she doesn't even put in a book
now she's just being basically asked
whether Trump eats children by various
members of the media it's like yeah a
trump each
yeah I know for a fact that he's got a
kiddin in a in a cage in the back of the
White House and he feeds that child to
fatten him up then he eats them so
Rachel Maddow last night at MSNBC asks
Mary Trump whether Trump uses the n-word
Nancy SMED explores and she like yeah
absolutely absolutely
where were you five years ago if this
was the case that seems like something
that would have been relevant when he
was running for president the first time
but apparently Mary Trump here to clean
up all the cash and uh new hero of the
Republic Mary Trump here here is Rachel
Maddow I have to press you on it a
little bit it's just to ask if the
president if your uncle was an exception
to that in your family or if he if you
if if you hurt you ever heard him
express either use anti-semitic slurs or
the n-word or other racist slurs or
other sentiments like that oh yeah yeah
of course I did and I don't think that
should surprise anybody given how
virulent lay raised as he is today
have you heard have you heard the
president used the n-word yeah and
anti-semitic slurs specifically yes
amazing amazing how that didn't make it
into the book incredible now breaking
news as I'm selling a book Trump use
that like by the way that would have
been the kill shot in 2016 what did if
not right like they're not not a lot of
people in America in in 2020 who aren't
fond of people using the n-word but
here's Mary look emerging from motoric
and Democrats like oh well you know cuz
that links with the American races
system and Trump is just the face of
that giant American races system now
coloring me a little bit skeptical on
this just a little bit skeptical but a
man who's been in the public eye for
nearly all his life and who has sought
the public eye for nearly all his life
routinely uses the n-word and somehow
nobody else has ever said that he uses
the n-word like this is the first person
in human history who said this I'm ooh
well she's selling a book mmm yeah I
mean I'm gonna go I'm gonna go skeptical
on that one again this is also part of
this is all part of the broader Muse
Matic attempt to paint everything in
America is racist so as to say that the
current President of the United States
is the is the biggest problem we get rid
of him and we can start to really do the
hard work I don't know if the memo went
out at major newspapers last night but
now classical music is under fire
there's a there's an article in the wash
in post called that sound you're hearing
is classical music's long overdue
reckoning with racism classical music
like do what they uncover some of
Mozart's old tweets or something what I
mean like vogner was pretty obviously a
Jew hater but I'm not sure what that has
to do with the price of tea in China
right now think that's that's weird okay
that's not the only article like this
there's a second article at the New York
Times saying that orchestras have to end
blind auditions why because they need
more faces of color well this is it's
this is absurdity like these came out
the same day by the way the memo went
out in the cultural world it was time to
go after classical music I very much
look forward to the vast media review of
rap music for racist misogynistic
homophobic and violent lyrics I feel
like they might get a little further
with that than with classical music is
inherently racist going after Brahms
according to the Washington Post however
the late great soprano Jesse Norman
receipt reserved just one chapter 424
memoir stand up straight and sing for
discussion of the discrimination she
faced so often throughout her career
even as one of the most decorated
performers on the international opera
stage but it's safe to assume race was a
running theme in her magnificent life
Addison emoti that emerged again and
again in the form of careless slurs and
slights from conductors TV roles that
would have reduced her from Dido onstage
to a maid on screen offensive questions
from bumbling critics nosy security
guards challenging her right to exist in
the hotel pool those who had imagined
that the rarefied realms of classical
music or opera are somehow removed from
the rancor of racism would be as Norman
put it mistaken sadly mistaken and so
too would those who imagined that our
nation's intensifying reckoning with
racial injustice merely marches past the
concert hall yes I'm sure that when most
protestors looked at an officer brutally
treating George Floyd what they were
thinking was you know what we need to go
down to the Metropolitan Opera House
right now and solve racism in dido and
aeneas
that's the front and center we need to
go after the Rossini operas must happen
data collected from 500 American
orchestras for 2016 study by the League
of American orchestras paints a starkly
white picture when it comes to diversity
in classical organizations its key
finding the proportion of non-white
musicians represented in the orchestra
workforce and of african-american and
Hispanic Latino musicians in particular
remains extremely low okay I just have
one question
have they ever recognized how many great
great Asian musicians there are his I'm
a classical violinist I'm playing since
the age of five disproportionately
over-represented among classical
violinists are Jews and Asians
hey that that's just the way it is both
minority groups but they don't count as
minority groups the only minority groups
who counts as minority groups our
minority groups who are seen as
victimized okay though and if you're if
you're too rich or if you're too
successful then you're not you're not
counted yeah it's it's it's an absurdity
how absurd is this it's so absurd that
again this brings us to the second piece
from the New York Times they want to get
rid of Blind Auditions there was a
theory a while ago that the reason there
weren't enough musicians of color in
Orchestra there's really female
musicians there weren't enough female
musicians in positions of power and
orchestras is because that when women
were trying out there was sort of these
evil sexist directors of orchestras who
would not give them the time of day
and so orchestras started using Blind
Auditions and counter to public
perception what actually happened is the
number of women in positions of power in
orchestras went down it turned out that
women were actually being kind of
slightly favored in some of those things
well now it turns out that the New York
Times wishes to get rid of Blind
Auditions
they literally want to make the
orchestra's worse they want to have
worse musicians so long as the diversity
photo looks appealing if ensembles are
to reflect the communities they serve
the audition process should take into
account race gender and other factors
according to Anthony Thomas Eenie over
at the New York Times in the critics
notebook Blind Auditions as they became
known proved transformative the
percentage of women in orchestras which
hovered under 6% in 1970 grew today
women make up 1/3 of the Boston Symphony
Orchestra they are half the New York
Philharmonic Blind Auditions changed the
face of American orchestras so by the
way I'm not sure the data actually
support this but he's now counting
against his own argument he's saying
Blind Auditions were good because they
allowed people who had historically been
discriminated against to get into
orchestras but now we need to get rid of
the Blind Auditions and have worse
musicians so that we can have more faces
of color in the orchestra I again I
really look forward to these standards
being applied to the NBA I think that we
need we need to get rid of Blind
Auditions for the NBA we need to
specifically seek out more Jewish
players in the NBA we need to seek out
more Asian players in the NBA we need
more people who are five five in the NBA
we do we need more
in the NBA it's an extraordinarily
non-diverse league why exactly are we
focusing in on the skill level of the
people who are playing why are we
focusing in on the diversity we need we
need a racially and in gender and sexual
orientation
representative NBA and if we don't have
that then it just ain't gonna work guys
we need we need people like you want a
man in the NBA we need it because if we
don't have that then the NBA is just not
in the first place they don't hear
anybody making that argument of course
because it's a stupid argument but you
start making about orchestras because
too many white people and all of a
sudden you are your woke and standing up
against racism now they're real bad
things happening the world right now
I mean truly evil things happening in
the world and we are ignoring all of
them in favor of this stupidity so we
are focused in like a laser beam on
Trump and Cova 19 and how he blew it
even though nobody has a handle on this
thing nobody no one has good handle and
don't give me that the United States has
a different has a different treatment
than Hong Kong again different strains
also different caseload from the very
beginning when focusing in on Trump from
SIBO we're focusing on Trump's of
fascist we're focusing in on classical
orchestras aren't diverse enough get rid
of Blind Auditions it meanwhile the
Chinese are literally sending Muslims
into concentration camps after shaving
their head on trains
remember that time people are like never
again after the Holocaust it's happening
like right now like right now there's
tape that has emerged of the Chinese
loading weaker Muslims onto trains and
then taking them to concentration camps
there is video of we Gers with their
heads shaved being shuttled into these
concentration camps if you will risk
their lives to break this sort of tape
this is hideous hideous stuff
what's the world doing about it nothing
what does the Americans left care about
not one whit about this now one iota
about this LeBron James
captain woke over here he's still
claiming that we don't properly
understand China the NVA is still trying
to make common cause of the Chinese III
that's not a misdirect it is a Mis
prioritization it is a Miss read of the
idea that America is uniquely evil that
that the American system is uniquely
evil to be so myopic that you focus only
on America when truly evil things are
happening around the world and when
America really provides the only bull
against that true evil is insane but
that's the world we now occupy an insane
world where we're supposed to be deeply
concerned deeply deeply concerned about
racism in classical music but you know
do we have a moment to spare for
millions people being shuttled into
abject slavery because of their religion
by people were doing a lot of business
with net not so much re time for a quick
thing that I like we're not so quick
thing that I like so yesterday I had the
privilege of having on vice president
Mike Pence on the radio show I thought
that it wasn't good an interesting
interview so here is what that sounded
like
joining us on the line his vice
president Mike Pence vice president
pence thanks so much for taking the time
I know you're very busy these days ben
shapiro it is great to be back with you
I'm speaking to you from the White House
and just thank you thank you for your
strong conservative voice on the
airwaves and on the internet all across
this country well thank you so much so
let's talk about the the biggest thing
on a lot of Republicans Minds these days
the campaign so obviously the campaign
has an uphill climb here I mean the
polling data right now so far is not
great what does the campaign plan to do
to turn this thing around it seems like
you kept a lot of ammunition in store it
seems as though the campaign really
hasn't gotten started thanks to a
variety of factors what do you think the
campaign is going to do to push forward
in the coming months well I think first
and foremost we're not going to pay any
more attention to the polls in this
election than we did in 2016 I just saw
a poll come out this morning that that
had us down double digits and a friend
reminded me that the exact same poll had
the president down double digits about
this time in 2016 so but look elections
are about choices I can't wait to get
out on the campaign trail I'll be in
Wisconsin tomorrow talking about
everything that we were able to
accomplish in the first three years of
this administration the president's
leadership through one this
extraordinary pandemic we continue to
move the nation forward we continue to
meet the needs of the American people of
families and making sure hospitalization
health care workers have the support
they need and we continue to see America
opening up you know we lost 22 million
jobs at the height of this pandemic but
given the foundation the strength of the
American icon
the foundation this president poured in
the first three years Ben we've already
seen nearly 8 million jobs returned
we're going to continue to open up
America open up America schools even
while we work every single day to put
this coronavirus in the past it's that's
the record we're going to take to the
American people and that record of
leadership and accomplishment build on
principles and free-market principles
growth will contrast so dramatically
with the the more taxes more regulation
big government social liberal agenda
that Joe Biden Bernie Sanders aoc Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer are going to
take to the American people so I I'm
confident about November 3rd we're going
to talk about the record we're going to
talk about the contrast we're going to
deliver a great victory for the American
people and vice president Penn's one of
the most difficult things that the
administration has had to deal with
literally since day one and before day
one has been the media bias against the
administration the media obviously
militating in favor of a variety of
causes none of which are particularly
good for the United States on occasional
just overtly ly after President Trump
gave what I thought was an excellent
speech at Mount Rushmore they simply
labeled it racist they were able to the
defense of Confederate monuments when he
didn't make a single reference to
Confederate monuments and that sort of
been the theme of the media throughout
this campaign and frankly throughout the
last few years has been the idea that
everything the president does is evil
and and wrong it was all about how the
president wasn't providing ventilators
when he was and then once the
ventilators were provided that sort of
just went away it was all about how the
president was involved with Russia and
when that went away then they just moved
on to the next topic how do you fight
back against a narrative in the media
that is so overwhelming and dominant and
and how do you fight back especially
when they are fear-mongering about Kovan
19 which is a very dangerous virus but
that doesn't mean that we can all live
in our basements from now until the
vaccine well I think we just continue to
tell the American people the truth we
tell the American people the truth about
what we accomplished in our first three
years I mean this president I actually
think been this president kept more
promises then he made to the American
people in 2016 I mean we rebuild our
military we renewed the constitutional
foundation under our courts more than
two hun
conservatives confirmed to our federal
courts and on the economy
this president cut taxes rolled back
regulation unleashed American energy
fought for free and fair and better
trade deals for the American people and
we saw seven million jobs created and as
I said that that laid a foundation with
with even with this pandemic striking
our nation from China oh the president
was able to ghin to marshal the
resources not just of the government but
the whole of America response where we
saw American ingenuity American
businesses stepping up we reinvented
testing we saw the creation of more than
a hundred thousand ventilators in a
hundred days no American who required a
ventilator was ever denied a ventilator
hundreds of millions of medical supplies
that we continue to surge as we see
outbreaks and increase in cases along
the Sunbelt and then you saw the news
this week I mean with with the advent of
new vaccines that are moving through
clinical trials at a record pace you
know I I have to tell you I have to tell
you Ben when when from from where I've
sat in this process despite the
criticism not just over the last three
and a half years but over the last four
months from the media I say I say only
with this president and only in America
and I have every confidence as we go
forward we're going to continue to take
that case and I will surely do believe
that there is greater enthusiasm for the
president and his agenda today than
there was at this time in the election
in 2016 so we're going to keep dealing
with this pandemic we're going to make
sure every state has everything they
need to provide for their citizens that
are impacted by the corona virus the
same level of health care you or I would
want for any member of our family but
we're going to keep opening up we're
going to open up our schools we're going
to keep telling the American people the
truth
and you're going to you're gonna see
this president and this team back in the
winner's circle on November 3rd vice
president pence you know the the other
aspect of our politics that seems to be
so dominant over the last few months is
this extraordinarily radical vision of
the United States to play steeped in ray
ISM bigotry in which all of our
institutions have been thoroughly
corrupted from inceptions resulting in
everything up to an including tearing
down statues of Thomas Jefferson
defacing statues of George Washington I
think connected to two larger scale
rioting and looting the Democratic Party
seems completely feckless in the face of
this sort of behavior how do you and the
president plan to take the message on
the road that there really is a threat
to some of the fundamental ties that
bind us in the United States well I
think as you said I think that's what
the Mount Rushmore speech was all about
and to some extent the July 4th speech
from the South Lawn of the White House
reiterated that look this is a president
that's going to defend America where we
from the founding of this country we
expressed a set of ideals and every day
in the long history of this country we
have marched toward a more perfect union
and the American people I think can be
proud of the progress that we've made we
can celebrate that progress even while
we continue we continue to aspire to
make those ideals more real for more
Americans I mean look and with regard to
the canceled culture that we have in
this country you're going to continue to
see the president and our entire team
stand up for the ideals of this country
and stand up for America but with regard
to to the whole issue of law and order
in law enforcement leaders I met
yesterday with the leaders of the top
law enforcement associations in America
then and there there is there's no
excuse for what happened to George floor
and justice will be served but there's
also no excuse for the rioting and the
looting and the destruction of property
in the end that and violence against
persons that followed this and and yet
we still see everyone from Joe Biden on
down talking about defunding the police
I mean did Joe Biden in an interview
just in the last week was asked if he
would if he would support transferring
funding out of police departments and he
said absolutely yes and members a lot of
members of the mainstream media are
denying that he said that but it's what
he said
and you know we're not going to defund
the police we're going to defend the
police we know you know most of the men
and women who put on the uniform of law
enforcement every day are the best
people in this country they every single
day they strap on a sidearm and they
count our lives is more important than
their own and we also know that nobody
hates bad cops more than good cops so
we're going to continue to look for ways
to fund the police to improve public
safety but we're not going to defund the
police we're going to we're going to
back the blue and and that's why I know
the president was so proud you received
the endorsement that he just received
from a major Police Association and I
truly do believe that whether it's the
economic record whether it's standing on
for all of our best constitutional
ideals the course whether it's
rebuilding our military whether it's
standing for law and order and with law
enforcement that I believe the majority
of the American people are with us and
not with Joe Biden and the radical left
and we're going to carry that message
all across this country every day
between now and November 3 we're
speaking with vice president pence Oh
vice president pence and the president
is unparalleled when it comes to
characterizing his opposition it's one
of his specialties he one of the best in
the history of American politics at
boxing in his opponents and certainly
labeling his opponents what is the
strategy with regard to Joe Biden
because it seems like there have been a
couple of tacks that have been tried one
is obviously that Joe Biden is not what
he used to be and then the second tack
is that Joe Biden is a lot more radical
than he is making it out I think that
frankly Biden is running a pretty smart
campaign by staying in the basement and
mouthing sort of platitudes that he
thinks appealed to a broad range of
Americans while sort of winking and
nodding at the radical left that makes
it kind of hard to characterize him how
does the president plan on going after
Joe Biden more specifically well we're
just going to talk about we're gonna
talk about the record because look Joe
Biden is a liberal than in Washington DC
for 40 years
but the Democratic Party today has been
overtaken by the radical left and all
you need to do is look at the fact that
here in the middle of a pandemic at a
time when American businesses are
starting to get back on their feet
people are going back to work even as we
continue to
ille with with outbreaks across the the
Sunbelt in this country Joe Biden
actually unveiled a plan to raise taxes
by four trillion dollars raise taxes by
nearly two trillion dollars on American
families and but two trillion dollars on
American businesses and and I have to
tell you we're going to we're going to
carry that message everywhere because at
the end of the day they're focused on
two things right now in this
administration and that is that is
saving lives and opening up America
again it's it's protecting the
vulnerable making sure our health care
workers have everything they need to
meet this moment and bringing our
country's economy back I mean with the
president's understood from early on is
that it's not a choice between the
health of the American people in a
growing economy it's a choice between
health and health we we have to have a
growing economy we have to open up our
country again
for the health and well-being of every
American and that goes equally for our
schools you know the president and I I
was in I was in Louisiana just a couple
of days ago where we're working we're
working with leaders in every state in
the country working with the CDC to get
our kids back to school you know you're
a parent you know I'm a parent my kids
are a little bit older than yours but
look we we know that that the risk of
serious illness on the coronavirus to
Americans under the age of 18 is very
low and with the CDC's guidance we know
that we can safely bring people these
young people back to school back to our
college and university campuses and yet
we're continuing to see Democrats around
the country push back on that and we're
going to keep opening up so it's it's
about talking about a plan of the
radical left that Joe Biden is standing
on a platform he's standing on but also
don't make don't don't leave out four
trillion dollars in tax increases but a
little bit later today we're going to be
on the South Lawn talking about all the
regulations that this president and his
cut in the last three and a half years
that have unleashed the American economy
Joe Biden also announced his version of
the green New Deal literally two
trillion dollars in in green subsidies
and I don't think I have to remind you
or your listeners about the Solyndra
deal in the last administration five
hundred million dollars down the drain
in a bankrupt solar company now they
want to spend two trillion dollars and
bring back the whole regime of cap and
trade to crush American energy crush
American energy independence it is a
pathway toward economic downturn it
would it will wage war on economic
recovery and and that's the message
we're going to take beyond all the other
issues having to do with the the culture
having to do with our ideals having to
do with the the right to life as strong
military and law enforcement we're going
to talk about our view for the economy
that that work before is working again
and Joe Biden's view that alittle
that'll hold this country back through
higher taxes and more regulation and
Vice President Penn's one other area
where there's a clear point of
differentiation is obviously with regard
to China where Joe Biden has a very long
record of being soft on China well what
exactly is the administration doing
given the fact that the Chinese have now
essentially reduced Hong Kong back into
a state of tyranny meanwhile there's
video emerging today of the Chinese
literally forcing Leaguers onto trains
which obviously brings up some rather
nasty imagery from the past and over a
million Weaver's who are living in
concentration camps at this point what
is the administration doing to counter
China these days no president in my
lifetime has been tougher on the Chinese
Communist Party than President Donald
Trump I mean when we took office after
eight years of the obama-biden
administration half of our international
trade deficit alone was with China a
country that had policies like forced
abortion and in the years that followed
we we saw the oppression of the weigert
population people literally being
marshaled into concentration camps and
then in recent days we saw them break
their work not just to the UK but to the
world about Hong Kong they made they
made a commitment
- - for at least fifty years that they
would respect the freedom the democracy
of the people of Hong Kong and they
unilaterally change that and that that's
why this president has taken strong
stands to impose tariffs on China with
those the vast majority of those tariffs
even with a phase one deal we did
continue to be in effect because China
has not opened up their markets yet with
regard to freedom of navigation you know
we have a we have a battle group two
aircraft carriers in South China Sea and
Secretary of State just reaffirmed our
nation's commitment the freedom of
navigation in the South China Sea we've
taken a strong stand for human rights
spoken out against the oppression of the
Muslim we Gers and as you saw earlier
this week the President signed an
executive order taking decisive action
changing the status of Hong Kong which
has been an economic asset for China
because they had a separate status from
China he's taking dramatic steps to hold
China accountable and will continue to
do that all of that said Ben I you know
this is a president that that that
believes in engagement in the world he
believes in dialogue we want a better
relationship with China we want better
for China but we're going to continue to
stand strong I'm going to stand strong
for basic human liberties and human
rights in China for a freedom of
navigation and we're going to stand with
the people of Hong Kong well miss
president pence really appreciate your
time and appreciate he's serving the
country the way that you do thanks so
much man it's great to be with you
thanks thanks for your Clarion voice on
the airwaves and all across this country
I look forward to talking to you soon
sounds great well folks that brings us
to the end of this week's show however
there are two more hours of content
coming away when you go to daily we're
calm and subscribe also make sure to
pick up a signed copy of my book how to
destroy America in three easy steps at
daily wire.com at /ban or pick it up
from amazon comment comes out next week
want to be one of the first to receive
it I think it's deeply important I think
that everybody should read it not just
because I wrote it but I think it
actually is a deeply important piece of
work otherwise have a great safe weekend
I
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling assistant
director Pavel white house key technical
producer Austin Stevens playback and
media operated by Nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam
SIA vets audio is mixed by Mike Rowe
Romina hair and makeup is by Nika Geneva
the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you